you have gotten so much better looking I
look good to look tremendous how much if
you lost 50 pounds you look all right
the hair is coming in in it this coming
from a man who looks like an elk pound
that was not genetically blessed I
shaved a little here and I took a little
out over there wouldn't have killed here
to wax you've heard about cellulite I
got it my legs look great my back the
thing that can't get rid of
what are we on doing out we had away
from Mayor Giuliani to close us down it
was from December 20th 1995
I decided to come on Dave show in drag I
get word Dave does not want you women's
clothing
he wants you to scent of you Howard I
said tell Dave to relax
there are giant greasy footprints all
over this desk I think Paul's a little
angry with me that day Paul are you
angry with mr. stern Howard thinks they
make fun I'll get back to you getting
high all the time I think I'd go smoke
my hands back Hey
why is a kite right days tell me the
crew know every night well no offense I
think you're injecting yourself into my
conversation a little too much here we
are 30 years later and what have we
learned
you're a guy I look up you're a guy I
look up to you and I are still deeply in
love I love you I love I love you babe I
love you
sometimes I say to myself maybe I should
elevate myself and then I realize I'm
the guy who comes on the Letterman Show
with no pants what am i elevated
certainly a full plate tonight from
Howard wasn't it